this morning on the dish a Chef Ludo
Lefebvre in Burgundy he was just 14 when
he started his culinary training working
with some of France's greatest chefs in
the 90s he brought his skills to Los
Angeles taking the helm at the famed
Laurel Laurel gently then came the
creative concepts he's become famous for
he pioneered the pop-up with his Ludo
bites he's thrilled fans of the French
bistro with La Petite wah and tois Mick
and even won the hearts of fried chicken
lovers with Ludo bird Ludo Lefebvre the
dish thank you so much for being here
this remarkable tool is like you are in
the French bistro okay almost like in
Paris okay so who you wish huh you wish
so here we have a lobster thermidor okay
very very classic dish you cook your
lobster put with a white sauce like a
bechamel and she's put everything
together put back in the shell back yet
with breadcrumbs that's it Lobster
Thermidor here you have some massage -
okay just mustard with shallowed white
wine cream of course is French
you know sword and lemon and pima
distillate here we have had a - you know
a little dish from south of France
okay lotta vegetable is that your
vegetables - here we have a little bit
of a massive Mandela you okay with no
butter just so you know surprising for
French food yeah one of my favorite
thing it's a Grey Goose expresso martini
this we lose less calories like a
dessert yeah it does it does you know
and I love this Grey Goose cocktail you
know it's like a substitution with
desert if you know what to desert you
can have a little bit of an espresso
martini and is less calorie a little bit
lighter for everyone I quote you're
somebody who just you grew up around
food you grew up in kitchens your mom
even nicknamed you the garbage disposal
yeah when I was a key that was eating
your lot I love to eat and I think
that's for that I become a chef you know
I was loved to spend time with my
grandma in the kitchen love to eat love
to get dirty in the kitchen and I just
love it I just
feels the food my son is like me too now
you guys six years old and exactly like
me eat a lot God your father right for
your first job your father took you I
think it was close to your first job
yeah Maxine's yeah and said give him the
worst job possible yeah I was 13 years
old and I was a very bad student okay
like little French Revolution a tribal
and my father was tired of me to get
kicked out of school
say you know what now you what you want
to do you want to be a tree solution you
can be a dresser you can learn the job
we'd be at the address recognition no
fitting car of your cook I decide to be
a cook because I love to it and that's
it but for make sure I love it
it put me to work in the restaurant it
was a friend of him and he thought you
were gonna hate it yeah he's actually
say tech to do with you and we can be
potato kinder froze the dishes hoodies
thing but I just love it I love it the
smell the son of the kitchen I just love
the energy in the kitchen you know I
love it and you you go from washing
dishes to then working with some of the
best chefs in France and then somehow
end up in California what why why
California yeah trying with the or the
Michelin star restaurant in France very
classic French food you know and I
decide to go to California did you know
anything about having you know nothing I
was not speaking English I mean you know
yourself as a culinary JYP's
oh yeah I'm just traveling wrong you
know and I was a lack of gypsy before
and now I'm steadily nearly but I come
20 years ago while in LA because I was
watching a lot of TV show you know which
one was badass 10 to the about Dallas I
knew everything about that are you yeah
you know it was pretty amazing about
guys thirsty but you know I grew up or
on food you know all my life you know
that's what what is the culture of
France and move your 20 years ago I was
a younger chef but now I'm Moody like
just focus on French food you know the
food at where I'm from and try to tell a
story try to talk about my culture in
France and try to give up here in
America because I would love this
country
and this country changed so much young
people love food now you know in America
just it's has changed once you first got
here and our Rukia
because I went to Italy was it for me
when I moved here to use a movie two
years ago it was like a revolution for
me because it's so many different
culturally region mix again yeah I'm
gonna have you sign our dish and as you
do I'll ask you if you could have a meal
with anyone past or present who would it
be my year oh it's I love Napoleon would
you serve Napoleon Napoleon book about
team I just love it I don't know why I
don't know I don't know put on you I
know it's so much for friends thank you
very much for more on Ludo and the dish
you can head to our website at CBS this
morning dot-com